[Music]
hi I'm Aaron I'm Albert and we're part
of the family that runs Din Tai Fung in
the United States
our grandpa opened the entire Fung in
1958 as a cooking oil retail store and
in 1972 he converted it to a restaurant
with only four tables and now because of
his dedication to service and the
quality of food it started getting
recognized abroad and that's really how
it started and it kind of grew from
there
Shaolin Bao means soup dumpling shouting
small loan means basket and by all means
dumpling so literally translated it
means little dumpling in a basket the
Shaolin bow was so special because
there's soup inside the dumpling which
makes it so hard to make it's just also
a food that's so different than anything
you've had before nothing really has
that first flavor in the mouth like a
soup dumpling does the Shaolin bow skin
is very basic ingredients flour water
and the fermented starter they go in the
mixer and we put in the machine for
several minutes after the dough is mixed
up the dough is placed into the dough
sheeter it takes about 6 to 10 times to
knead the dough to create that perfect
shallow bowel skin
Schama is really a very difficult name
to make especially up to then typing
standards because we really
every dumping to be the same so it takes
three to six months for someone to even
learn the basics of how to make the
shell mouth and it takes years and years
to truly master the craft and making it
it felt really good finally made one
that was up to the quality of the entire
phone because probably made like ten
thousand that we had to throw away
before we made the first one I would
spend months and years practicing and it
was really nice finally being able to
cook lunch and being able to sell it up
to the quality that we achieve every
single dumpling is way down to the gram
including every single dumpling skin so
the ideal weight that we're going for is
5 grams we don't pass anything unless
it's between 4.8 or 5.2 grams so I think
the way we make our dumplings skins is
really special because we make it
thinner on the outside rim and thicker
in the center and the reason for that is
because with the thinner outside edge
you can make a very delicate crinch so
that you don't have a very big knot at
the top of the dumpling if we definitely
pride ourselves on having the thinnest
scales along the shell and all stores
out there so everyone needs to work very
quickly because the skin dries out in
the manner of just a couple minutes
everything needs to be have extremely
fresh to deliver
the best quality to our customers the
flavor of a soup dumpling a lot of it
comes from the soup itself and we make
the soup from a really rich bone broth
of chicken and pork and from there we
have to figure out how to get the soup
into the dumpling and the way we do that
is by gelatinizing the suit and turning
it into a jello form and then once that
you're able to wrap it up in a dumpling
when you steam it it turns back into a
soup over the years since I Fung is
discovered that eighteen folds is the
golden ratio it brings a perfect amount
of both texture and the best aesthetics
is a eat Shalom bow that we bake so a
lot of restaurants they make this show
about with a machine or they make a lot
of them and freeze them but here at Din
Tai Fung we don't really care about
making the process easier we think that
even though a machine makes it easier
you lose a lot in the process because
it's such a delicate food so we choose
to make our dumplings by hand and to
order we steamed them inside of a bamboo
steamer we think that's actually really
important a part of the flavor component
of the dumpling because some of that
bamboo flavor ends up seeping into the
skin
[Music]
you're eating it for the first time it's
really special because when you bite
into it you get really an explosion of
flavors from the soup you know kind of
bursts out when it's in your mouth man
it's just like truly unique experience
there's a lot for us to take over the
business because you know we pretty much
grew up in this environment and we
really think it's important that we have
the opportunity to pay if entick Chinese
cuisine to the mainstream and really
change people's perceptions of what
Chinese cuisine can be brings great
prior to me when one of our customers or
guests come up to us and they tell us oh
how proud we are bringing this Chinese
experience the United States and just
how proud they are to be Chinese and it
really means a lot to us
[Music]
you